EMILY KAPLAN WILL BE TALKING  O
THAT IS STOPPED BACK
AND MOVING IN ON A T -- GO!
WHAT A BEAUTIFUL PASS FRFRKOVSK
GOOD FINISH.
GOOD START HERE FOR COLORADO.
PORTUNITIES. GIANT, HUGE,
LIFE-SIZE -- MORE THAN LIFE
SIZE OF BRIAN BOUCHER. RST PERI
HERE IS FOX.
IT ROLLS OFF HIS STICK.
BURAKOVSKY.
GEORGIEV.
JUJU
DOWN LOW.
SCORE!.
RYAN STROME WIOF STROME.
BUT I HAD TO PLAYAYAND RIGHT BA
GOT THE RIGHT LEG OUT.
ANDIT BACK.
KADRI -- FIRST  ON THE DRIVE
FROM MAKAR, THE SECOND POWER
PLAY GOAL . IT ALL
STARTS WITH THE ARE THE RANGERS
HE SAID, WHY NOT?
>> AFTER VIDEO REVIEW, THERE
WAS NO --NG --
WRIST SHOT -- DEFLECTED BY DOOR
AND TEMPER PRIMAS ABLE TO STILL
ALIVE SOMEHOW -- STOP THAT
LITTLE PITCH SHOT -- AND CAN'T
HOW ABOUT THE SAVIOR?PLAY STAYS
ALIVE.
PRESSING RIGHT NOW.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS SEQUENCE BY
DARCY KUEMPEAVALANCHE -- SECOND
PANARIN WAS